you're supposed to fail failing is all
failing as is learning this you know one
size fits all philosophy didn't work
there's two things your control what do
you eat and what you do physically
everything else in the world whether
your friends work your kids you don't
have a shot okay you wholly hope you
have some control and all those
categories of your life like that till
you control save your life
hey guys welcome to the bow show today
my guest is someone who I would rarely
bestow the title of guru on to but today
we're gonna do it
it's fitness guru and one of the most
influential and innovative people in
fitness and health is Tony Horton how
are you brother tony Horton's here oh
hey that's me I'm great ball thanks for
having me on man I'm fired up thanks for
being here man this is such an important
episode because we have hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of videos in this
channel
millions of people constantly looking
for inspiration that next thing that's
going to get there however what I'm
seeing is people are not taking their
health seriously they're not taking
exercise seriously they're not taking
that frame of mind because for me it's
you need to take care of this body so
you can live long enough to see your
empire built so I just from hearing from
you I'd love to know and you can tell
these people there's no one better to
say it the importance of health in just
not just running your business but
running your life well you know it's
interesting I there's a lot of
entrepreneurs out here in California you
know it's like sort of the land of
entrepreneurs right and I see so many
people with a nose to the grindstone
working so darn hard to build their
businesses you know because it's not
easy being an entrepreneur you're not
working for the man this is you you're
you're covering all you know all the
territories when it comes to making sure
your business grows and you're
absolutely right a lot of people are
sort of skipping the the exercise and
diet portion of their life right and a
lot of them aren't getting enough sleep
they're stressed out they're dehydrated
you know they're on the go store they're
eating garbage food you know I can only
speak for myself but I've seen a lot of
people make that shift where they begin
to understand the importance of
exercising eating right and they
understand that how
improves the quality of their life
tenfold above and beyond the the
aesthetic purposes you know I mean we
all want to look good and you know have
a good shape and be able to function on
this earth but the reality is is when
you exercise it improves memory and
cognition and sex drive and productivity
and you know it's across the board
because it's not just a physical thing
it's a mental emotional and for some
people a spiritual thing and so for me
it comes down to behaving in such a way
exercising in such a way eating in such
a way so that it it affects your energy
and enthusiasm for who you want to be
what you want to do and how you want to
accomplish this journey of being an
entrepreneur and so when you're
overweight you're typically overwhelmed
often because you don't have not only
the physical but the mental and
emotional capacity to be able to build
the business that you want to build your
very very very successful in your field
but not only that you're you're an
entrepreneur yourself and guys Tony
knows what he's talking about so if he
Tony speaks you listen and what I find a
stand is you had the biggest-selling
fitness program of all time
p90x p90 and what are just what started
you from who you were to get you onto
this journey going okay I'm gonna be in
this business I'm gonna be making people
becoming the best version of yourself
well our people hear this story and I
think really is that really how it
happened but you know I was not an
athletic kid I had two left feet I was
picked last for every team you know I
wanted to be a good athlete it just
wasn't you know I didn't have good
teachers and coaches and mentors you
know when I grew up in the 60s and 70s
back on the East Coast a lot of the
coaches back then we're just how to
gravitate it to the natural athletes
kids that were just sort of better at it
than I was and so I was left you know I
was left in the and the wings hoping
wanting wishing but just wasn't
achieving everything changed when I came
out to California I mean I did a little
weightlifting class in college back at
the University of Rhode Island and I
liked the DA like the teacher he was
unique in the sense that he wasn't a
bully and he really took his time you
know a lot of the teachings that I do
now a lot the way I disseminate my
philosophies mint methods and techniques
stems from the way he would communicate
us he had a sense of humor he made it
fun like never in my life I'm lifting
weights right I'm doing push-ups and
pull-ups and curls and squats and
deadlifts and all these different things
and I looked forward to it unlike my
experience back in high school so that
was sort of the spark you know it was
this century as the Japanese say you
know that sudden moment of enlightenment
then they came up to California and a
lifestyle out here was just different
you know I mean it's sunny 322 days out
of the year so people are skiing surfing
and playing volleyball and there's you
know there's all the tracks everywhere
local high school tracks and and I
joined World Gym which is where Lou
Ferrigno and Arnold Schwarzenegger we're
spending their time and I would cheat
and spy on them you know taking notes
from those two guys but I also had a
friend of mine most a track athlete so
he showed me a lot of a lot of the stuff
that would happen at the track so I
started doing that and I'm still playing
tennis and some golf and some other
things but I just noticed early on
unbeknownst to me that I wasn't changing
my brain chemistry as a result I didn't
go into it for that reason I wanted to
be buff so I can beat chicks you know
what I'm saying so you know that was it
and that's what most guys in their 20s
do you know all right if I work out then
I have more confidence tell me ladies
but it turns out you also need a
personality huh hmm so I was an actor
too at that time and I was doing my
improv classes and my scene study
classes and I attempted stand-up for a
couple of years that was fun and nothing
like getting booed on a stage at two
o'clock in the morning with four people
the audience that are so drunk they
don't even know where you are but it
thickens the skin my friends and that
was all part of my early days I would go
to I was a member of four different gyms
at one point because I like the variety
thing I mean if you look at power 90 or
p90x x2 x3 all these programs have
created 22-minute hardcore and many
others is there's a ton of variety in
them it's not just weightlifting so
that's just body it's not just cardio
it's not just martial arts it's all of
the above because it forces you to work
on your weaknesses and back in the early
days I was only doing that
partly I go to Pilates and yoga classes
for the ladies but I was learning a lot
at the same time and I was going to you
know world gym with Lou Ferrigno and
Irish Wars snigger know the body
builders because I wanted to I wanted
that aspect of my fitness as well so I
was trying to prevent boredom injuries
and plateauing which is what happens to
most people which is why they don't get
the results that they want because
they're doing this myopic
thing this you know one size fits all
philosophy didn't work and so that was
it I was I didn't even know I want to be
an actor I wanted to be Jim Carrey and
Tom Cruise all wrapped in one you know
but that was hard so I wasn't able to
accomplish that but because I was
working on the comedy and the improv and
the scene study stuff I was getting
uncomfortable it's getting comfortable
in front of a group of people in front
of an audience in front of a camera and
so the fitness thing just came out of
the blue a friend of mine worked for
NordicTrack and he's sort of seen my
journey and he said I'd love you to come
up to Minnesota up there at Minnesota
you know and shoot some stuff with
NordicTrack and you know I could walk
and chew gum which you know I was I had
a fitness background plus I could you
know read the teleprompter and do two
things at once those are the early days
for me then I did I was in the
ThighMaster commercial if you can
believe that one way back Suzanne Somers
you know a real high you know and then
and then Carl Daikeler this now the CEO
of Beachbody you know we became friends
early on to a mutual friend and before
you know I was doing this thing called
great body guarantee my first real
on-camera instructional workout series
and I was a little stiff back then all
right everybody here we go we're gonna
do curls now and one you know and then
you know Carl got to know me you say wow
you bring out your personality why don't
you just go nuts and if you go too far
well do another take and all of a sudden
everything clicked you know everything
clicked power 90 didn't have it so much
but when p90x came out everybody went
like wow who's this Fitness clown this
guy's out of his mind
and it worked because of the variety
number one was already ingrained in who
I was as a trainer with a lot of my
celebrity clients and and then the the
modifications no one had really showed
people one two and three ways to do a
particular exercise you know it's like a
progression instead of everybody in the
back being perfect being tan nobody's
sweating and everybody's nailing it you
know we got real people who've been to
the test group or behind me or hate me
cursing me out and struggling and
everybody at home went wow this feels
like the real deal and you know I don't
know how many millions of copies later
but quite a few and so that was the that
was the journey and
you're here talking to me how about your
stud come on know what I think is not
just your journey but people can take
away something into your story there a
variety will so many people hit plateaus
and they get kind of they get
disheartened and by having that variety
changing the way they're doing things
with the main goal in mind would you say
that would is quite necessity in the
entrepreneur lifestyle well you know if
you look a lot of entrepreneurs I think
the ones that most are most successful
in the end are not afraid to reinvent
the wheel you know because everybody
follows a formula okay if I follow this
formula I'll be successful well maybe
that formula worked for somebody else
before you but that not might not be
your technique your strategy whatever
happens to be it might not be your
methods so you know you got to think
outside of the box was an entrepreneur
you know and if some don't work don't do
it again
you know you might want to try another
angle you know what I mean when it comes
to your process when it comes to dealing
with the people who you work with or you
know whatever kind of creative process
that you're in I mean you really have to
kind of look at it and say alright what
is unique and special about me as an
individual how do I look at this thing
what is unique about this product or
this process or this course or whatever
I'm trying to create that is unique to
me and most people sort of have a
tendency to stray away from that they
try that and it's okay to emulate you
know that's not a big deal like you know
you look at Tony Robbins or Elon Musk or
anybody who's amazing in their field you
think okay I'm gonna take a piece of
that I'm not gonna take the whole thing
because that's not the whole thing's not
me but I'm gonna take a piece of what
twenty Robbins does if you look at Who I
am on the combination Tom Petty Billy
Idol Andrew Weil Deepak Chopra Gary
Zhukov you know my my college fitness
coach like oh I like that you know I
like that I like that phrase I like that
technique I like that method and you
sort of you know you reinvent yourself
you're growing and changing and
transforming over the course of years I
mean you know you don't wanna you don't
want to behave and act and proceed with
that if you're doing the way you did ten
years ago because it's probably stagnant
and old and old-fashioned and antiquated
right
and so now what you want to try to do is
okay what's new what's fresh what are
the kids doing you know what our kids
want do the research you know I don't
understand what your demographics are
and there's a lot to do and
oh by the way you're gonna fall down
again and again and again and again and
it really depends on how many knows you
can handle you know I mean let's say
okay I'm gonna handle a hundred nose
today and if you go in if you go in that
way and and you're understand that the
nose are coming because of there's
something you're doing that isn't
working
so you gotta do something different
Einstein whoever said it you know
insanity is repeating the same things
over over again expecting a different
result everybody knows that by now it is
tried-and-true so and that's it and and
exercise what does exercise fit in that
it changes the way your brain functions
faster truly does your brain is more
capable of being pliable in situations
that are difficult and when you exercise
you're releasing norepinephrine dopamine
serotonin brain-derived neurotropic
factor that's right molecules and
proteins coming together inside you're
now gonna change the way you're gonna
get stuff done and without exercise it's
just I can't and then you repeat those
mistakes over again and you eat a double
cheese chimichanga and you wonder why
you're taking a nap to three o'clock in
the afternoon I feel lucky that I can't
eat that stuff because I dunno I just
feel like I need to fuel myself and I
know that my success in my life up to
this point has been the turning point
was when I got I took my health and
fitness seriously but a key point I want
to kind of hit on what you said there is
taking bits and pieces of people to
create yourself there was a great in the
you to documentary at Bono when he
reinvented himself in the 90s and he
took Jim Morrison's jacket and Elvis's
glasses and this and that's how he
became who he was and this channel as
well we've got hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of videos top tens on like Elon
Musk Deepak Chopra all these people I
think Billy Idol's on there they'll be
cool right Billy I trade bill you know
right I heard it's awful it's an awful
impression everyone from England saying
Horton shut up with that hideous Roy is
more like tell me we didn't shoulders
and triceps today great oh my anyway I
apologize I apologize to the play oh no
we love it he's Billy Idol's of doing
amazing fur he just keeps going just
keeps going man going he formed it a big
event that Beachbody did he brought me
up on stage we sang
rebel rebel yell together I mean you
know drop the mic I was done that was
just the most insane moment but I
trained him on and off for 17 years I
learned there's a lot of Billy in me boy
it really is just because he's such a
huge personality such a mega talent it
was fun fun times well it's not you've
trained some incredible people like
recently I saw on Instagram you're with
you and McGregor who's a national
treasure here we protect you and he's
very much loved in the UK but you know
the reason the these hi big well-known
clients are coming to you is because
they believe in what you do they know
what you can do so guys when I'm saying
we've got Tony Horton on here we want
you guys to start your journey looking
into his fitness programs into his
living large program and that I mean it
and I as everyone knows I don't get
people onto this show unless I really
believe in them so in that story there's
so many nuggets you can take out because
your journey again you said failure is
okay it's you're gonna fail I know I
felt you're supposed to fail it's the
best bailing is all failing is is
learning they should just we should
change we should here's what failure
should be every time you think of the
word failure think of awesome learning
moments failure awesome learning moments
and so you gather that Intel and you
don't forget about it you know you say
okay well this happened and that happen
and that phone call didn't go well and
that you know he broke the contract or
you know whatever it is okay so how do I
do it differently next time or maybe you
don't do it differently maybe you're
just dealing with the wrong people I
mean honestly it's it's really a matter
of persistence and determination in a
work ethic and having a purpose in a
plan and in reverse engineering things
at some time like I wrote that up in my
book the big picture like if you're
gonna go to Mount Kilimanjaro right how
do you like what's the process to go
from home I want to go climb Kilimanjaro
okay well that's in Africa I live in you
know the United States so what do I have
to do and how many months in advance and
who should I bring with me and you know
you see yourself at the top of the
mountain right there just farm in the
air here we are you know snow all around
you what are the day before look like
that means you know you won't know
exactly you can't predict the future but
you get have a general idea that it's
gonna be how many steps or yards or
meters or whatever it is between the top
of the mountain and before and the day
before that a day before that
piñon then you figure out how much what
am I going to bring what kind of kid
conditioning I am I gonna do it's gonna
be nineteen thousand feet you Google all
that stuff you know I mean you talk to
people who've been there and you just
kind of break it down before you go so
it's not as intimidating it's the same
thing as building your business like you
see maybe for some people it's just you
know X amount of dollars or something
you know net profit or something like
that and you say okay X amount of dollar
what I got to do and reverse engineering
things hypothetically is a brilliant way
to build your confidence when it when it
comes to you know moving forward
regardless how many times you fall down
people there's gold in this interview
keep watching gold telling you and
silver and platinum damn it start
digging where you don't need to dig it's
all on the surface but a few people
found out that I'd be talking to you
today and a lot of them were kind of one
of the big questions like my good friend
Ben he's like he lost a ton of weight
because of of your programs he was very
good and he said it would just he's now
started a CrossFit gym in Miami and he's
doing incredibly successful and and he's
trying to inspire more entrepreneurs and
he's got a big following and one of the
things he asked me to kind of if I could
get draw it out of you awesome and it's
probably one of the easiest things you
use know is what small changes one or
two that people who've never been into
this lifestyle could start to do to
start to change their life well I would
say number one is I think the reason why
a lot of people aren't successful with
their fitness is because they wake up in
the morning with the greatest intentions
in the world but they'd haven't really
planned what it is they're gonna do and
what time they're gonna do it and so you
know I tell people to go buy a wall
calendar and stick it up someplace where
you're gonna see it every day your
bathroom mirror is one your refrigerator
is the other one and then maybe the back
of your front door so it just stares you
in the face and prior to the beginning
of any month you just write down in your
own handwriting okay Monday I'm gonna do
plyo Tuesday I'm gonna do shoulders and
arms Wednesday's gonna be cardio you
know just kind of write them down and
you write down what time you're gonna do
this so you set that schedule like you
do everything else in your life and it
becomes Priority One because you want to
now you understand that if I move
physically today I'm better today
physically mentally emotionally that's
the truth
across the board I don't care who you
are if you're from Tanzania or the South
Pole or you're 85 or you're 25 that is
the universal truth Fitness makes you
better today because it affects the
noggin in your
state of get-up-and-go better than
anything else and then you probably
ought to not for everybody but you want
to try to find somebody else to connect
with when you do it it's always you're
always more successful when you have a
partner your husband your wife your kids
your neighbor your coworker or whatever
does hey come on man
we're gonna do this for 90 days let's
just do it we're done talking you and me
we're gonna schedule it we're gonna meet
I'll meet at your house three days a
week you meet at my house three days a
week thing is done you know what I mean
and so that is not rocket science I mean
it's not like what I just said is
impossible you're not digging ditches
and splitting atoms okay
you're just scheduling a workout with
somebody you're showing up and being
awful some days and have a great energy
some days and having no energy some days
some days you're strong some days you're
weak don't judge it don't judge it stop
judging it you're judging it don't judge
it enjoy the journey
journeys the whole darn thing that's the
story you look back and go some days I
was awesome some days I sucked okay so I
but I did it and I showed up number two
food it's all about what you put your
mouth there's a healthcare crisis in
this country and there's other ones I
don't know how I pad it is in the UK
right now it's because we can't figure
out how to control our gob in a frickin
hands it's about the gob in the hands of
iya Slee there's something going on in
here because there's a hole you're
trying to fill with your gob in your
hands and what you want to do here there
is write that down make two lists and
put them on your refrigerator foods that
you intrinsically know that are healthy
fruits vegetables whole grains lean
proteins and healthy fats put all of
those on that list and then you write
above that list you write eat this okay
and on the other side you put all the
stuff that your nose colors the problem
the mallomars the double cheese
chimichangas the four beers at the
soccer at the football game we'll put
all that over there and you're right
not this okay and then you see how well
you do and those two lists are there
right there there's a good list in the
bad list and you you know you don't have
to be you know persnickety about it but
you want to try to eat over here and not
eat over here because if you do this and
you exercise it with your pal in 90 days
boom biceps sixty-year-old
and there's this little friend okay so
aging is for idiots it's for people who
aren't willing to do the work to figure
out how to get her done it's that simple
and once you get that formula figured
out both like your
it was like I'm overweight I'm unhappy
now I'm gonna do p90x now I don't want
across the gym in Miami and I'm a star
and that can happen anybody and
everybody because guess what there's two
things your control what do you eat and
what you do physically everything else
in the world the weather your friends
the work your kids you don't have a shot
okay you wholly hope you have some
control and all those categories of your
life but that till you control save your
life actually before we even spoke one
of the posts that I'm kind of a
motivational quote that I put on my
four-minute masters page today was you
can control three things ooh what you
how much you exercise what you eat and
what you think you can control your
thoughts for sure man for sure
absolutely I like I'm gonna steal that
I'm stealing brother what Tony's gone on
there guys is motion equals emotion so
by changing your physical state you're
gonna start changing how you feel like
we are all familiar with the Anthony
Robbins Superman exercise where you
pretend to put on a cape and walk down
the street you're gonna feel a million
bucks it's just the way it is so if
you're moving get an accountability
partner someone who's gonna be there
with you it's more success that way and
the last thing is there you need to fuel
your body right and there's so many
resources out there and I know that
every program you do it does come with a
nutritional program to follow so they
don't think you're just gonna be in the
wilderness in the wild not knowing what
to do well you know one of them tiny bit
on add to that and and it's interesting
information is not enough for from many
many people for some people the
educational process is a is a direct
line to transformation and success but
for a lot of people there's just there's
just too many mental and emotional and
psychological things that get in your
way as a result of a of a mind that
doesn't doesn't solve problems well
because of lack of exercise I mean it's
all about chemicals you know what I mean
you look at people with PTSD and other
other different things whenever and
almost anybody with any kind of ailment
exercises in eats better they're doing
all kinds of John rady's a friend of
mine he's written a book spark and he
works with autistic kids and these kids
are moving five times a day
and they eat fruits and vegetables man
there is no fat sugar salt or chemicals
anything they eat and these kids you
know maybe they're not super high
functioning but there's nice and
improvements purely as a result of what
they eat and how they move and that
happens with almost anybody so as a
young entrepreneur you know you can go
to every seminar I read every book and
do these different types of things but
if you really want to go into turbo mode
then you eat right and exercise it just
accelerates your your the possibilities
would you say that the discipline that
you earn and you do earn it by
completing like a 90-day intensive or
something that carries into your other
actions in business and your kind of
decision-making and carves you as a
person it makes me less fearful I'm a
fearful scaredy-cat without it I truly
am I just feel like the world is
overwhelming and nothing's gonna work
out and Who am I and why am I so special
I still suffer from that you know it's
the level like whatever I'm sick or
something and I missed more than two
days of workouts I get that a little low
as me thing you know I'm not here to
pronounce that I'm you know mr. mr.
giddy up and get it done all the time
there's Evan flow and my you know I
don't sometimes it's barometric pressure
and biorhythms and and you know not
enough sleep and maybe too much salt my
dinner I can't control a lot of things
you know what I mean but I can control
movement and I can control hydration and
I can control you know how much I eat
and when I do those things the odds go
up and not every day is perfect I mean
I'm not proclaiming that's gonna happen
for anybody I don't know who you are but
the ultimate goal here is joy happiness
and laughter really I mean it's joy
happiness and laughter I mean what's the
opposite of joy happiness and laughter
it's all those things that you don't
want it's all the things that make you
sad and gloomy and depressed and
overwhelmed all right so if I move today
I I can push that part of the way my
brain might go by by moving and eating
well and and getting sleep and hydration
it's more than just those two things but
it's it's just basically healthy
behavior and so you want to up the odds
because it's about joy happiness and
laughter that's what it's about well I
know from me
as someone I my life I had a privileged
childhood and then in my early 20s we
lost everything became homeless and I
succumbed to anxiety depression and the
kind of the true meaning of like PTSD I
had a traumatic event and I had stress
from it and I didn't know what to do and
it was through movement through exercise
through yoga Pilates and that I found
who I was again and I was fat bo and
then I was squidgy Bo and now I'm tone
Bo but I'm happy with that because what
it did for me was it realized I can
control this so and then next thing I
know my thoughts I can start moving my
thoughts in the right direction and boom
so from I think just everyone on this
channel and everyone who's watching
thank you so much for doing what you do
in the world and I think I just if one
more person learns about it two more
people
it is gonna change it's going to change
the world because someone's gonna live
longer they're gonna be there to see
their grandkids their great grandkids
they're gonna be there to enjoy more
sons they're gonna see more innovations
like every day L almost seems to be
coming up with something amazing don't
you want to be a life to see that I do I
do man I'm gonna I'm gonna be done at
109 I figure out a 9 I'm gonna look like
crap you know what I mean but but but I
want to try to go I try to go long you
know I mean I was like I still still
suffering from vestibular issues from
Ramsay Hunt syndrome that I had back in
October it lasted about five months it
was a brutal time timeframe for me but
it was the diet and the sleep and the
hydration and the exercise that brought
me back not a hundred percent it's one
of these things that sometimes takes a
year or more but actually there's a an
athlete an English athlete Lissie yarn
Auld who won gold two years in a row has
the same thing that I had so you know I
used her as an inspiration one of your
fellow countrymen that really inspired
me to no matter what you know ten
o'clock at night Jackson Hole it's minus
four degrees outside and I go you know
because Lizzie one golden career she's a
badass so she can do it I can do it and
it really know what inspires you that's
the most important thing as an
entrepreneur what keeps you going what
keeps that light on you know I mean it
could be anything and everything and if
you do they die in the exercise the odds
for your success go way up
one more thing I want to say there's
anything Tony or you're interested in go
to Tony Horton life.com check me out
I'll be at the Omega Institute in in New
York
Darren Ilene a great great event the two
of us the 27th through the 30th in San
Diego if you want to sign up tickets are
up for sale I just got the link I'm
gonna tell you right now I'm gonna read
it because I'm gonna get it right the
Paragon XP eventbrite.com that's the
Paragon exp eventbrite.com it's gonna be
an amazing four days amazing speakers
rock and roll artists gonna be that
they're gonna jams gonna be fine and I
hear you're gonna be doing your Billy
Idol impression so everyone's gonna love
it
right great I was gonna sing rebel yell
but then that'll be that'll destroy me
how great this interview is console just
one last question and it's what we asked
all of the best of the best
it's Evans big thing it's what launched
Evan into stardom and Evans lives by his
one word and Evans one word is believe
and he wants people to believe in
themselves he believes in himself and
unlocking that my one word is incredible
I want to do incredible things I won't
be around incredible people talk to
incredible people everything my
experience is incredible do you have a
word that you embody and go that's me
you know God one you can maybe pick one
oh you know I was gonna pick love cuz
just love all you need is love but I'd
have to say humor mine is humor when I'm
when I'm when I'm laughing because of
humor or I'm making people laugh there's
just I just feel so present under those
conditions was a great interview with
the Pope and he said the two things that
are most important for mankind is a
smile and humor and I went oh yeah and
like that so I'm gonna go with humor
I've been smiling this whole my face
hurts from just laugh-in smilin soul
interviews it's been one of my favorites
but guys we're gonna put all the links
below for everything and do check out
Tony's course with Brendon Burchard
livin large it's fantastic thank you
that's not just health and fitness
that's Tony's principles to how he looks
into success so guys I started with
personal development that's how I got
going I didn't get that in school
personal development launched me into
fitness and health and where I am now
so it's a course it's really it's
autobiographical in some respect you
know is my journey from being stuck and
and and upset about where I was going to
making dramatic change and it's a fun
course there's a lot of humor in that
one - Oh strange you say about courses
because I used to be a rock musician and
toured the world and now I'm
interviewing gurus and masters all over
it's very strange but I just go with it
man but you got a great journey Bo
you're doing a lot of things this is
amazin amazing thing you're doing you're
affecting a lot of people these these
sessions with me and other folks that
are influencers in our world you know
not everybody has access they don't have
direct access to me you know they go
they have to come to events and
different things and I don't get to talk
this long you know we'll do Q&A so it's
powerful what you're doing and thank you
for having me on well thank you very
much and I'm just doing this because I
want people to basically become the best
versions of themselves and you could be
one of those pieces that so ignite
something in someone and they go you
know what tomorrow I'm gonna not gonna
have my big ass latte with my donor I'm
just gonna look into maybe one of your
programs and just start yes all we can
hope for all we can hope for brother but
guys thank you so much this has been the
Bo show as you can see we are on a roll
with guests so Tony any last words
before we go
bring it get some live large that's it
all I gotta say I love it
guys we'll see you for another Boat Show
soon hey brother bye bye hey guys I hope
you enjoyed that interview with Tony
Horton the guy's a powerhouse and I had
so much fun recording that interview if
you watch it again you'll just see me
smiling the whole way through the reason
I got one of the best fitness experts on
the planet I'm here for you guys is
because I wanted to change your life
like you've changed millions of people's
of lives because the belief is if you
can look after this your body and you
can take care of this temple that means
you're gonna have better control of your
mind that means it's going to alter your
decisions and your finances your
businesses your relationships your
entire life and also when you feel good
about yourself the confidence that you
gain to go into the world you're gonna
make decisions you didn't even know
we're possible I really believe that
we're put on this planet and we should
at least at one point in our life see
the best version of ourselves
so why not physically become that best
version of ourselves
the variety Tony talks about is not just
weight training but also plyometrics
cardio lifting weights
yoga Pilates you can do some dance
whatever it gets you going but that
variety is the spice of life and by
applying that approach to your business
a variety of approaches to a destination
you might knock on doors you never knew
possible the other thing I took away
from this interview was Tony's one word
Tony's one word was humor and humorous
such a big part of my life because I
know when I feel good and I'm laughing
it's impossible for me to feel bad and
sad and negative and depressed and I
know that humor and exercise together
got me out of depression and anxiety and
PTSD I know that got it out of me so
guys I really recommend you start
looking into your health start eating
better start working out because you
want to live long enough to see the
empire's that you're gonna create and
also start laughing more if you want a
quick laugh go onto YouTube and look up
those videos with cats and cucumbers
they always give you a laugh so guys I
hope you took away something amazing
from this just another part that's gonna
turn you into the ultimate version of
yourself and you're gonna change the
world by doing this so until we see you
on the bow show next time if you have
any comments on this video please put
them below I'd love to hear from you
if there's anyone you want to see on
this channel just let me know because
I'm open to all kinds of guests so have
a wonderful day wherever you are in the
world and we'll see you in front of the
bow show soon if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like I
am Tulsa what a whale out of handcuffs
lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 254 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
description below to get access